so yeah thank you slowly my name is
Frank Kelly it's a pleasure to come here
and speak at PI data in this glamorous
location I'm gonna talk about
hierarchical clustering can everybody
hear me okay yep it louder so yeah can I
have a show of hands who here uses
clustering on a regular basis let's see
probably about half so and who has used
hierarchical clustering okay third let's
say okay okay good to know
so I talk it's gonna I didn't know how
to approach it but I decided to start
with a bit of theory looking at to the
origins of clustering itself some go
into hierarchical clustering as a method
look at some perform performance metrics
things you can use and then and then go
across to Python looking at scikit-learn
and just talk a bit about my my own use
case I'm currently working on and at the
end I was going to focus on some
visualization options so Who am I so my
I am actually a say I'm a data scientist
but I studies engineering so
masquerading as a data scientist but I
did I did study electrical information
Sciences so it's as close as you can be
to computer science and yet still be an
engineer and you can say I've worked for
10 years as an engineer because I've
worked in several different countries
including Norway that's reference to her
Norwegian and I'm not heavy I haven't
been a heavy Python user up until quite
recently in my most recent roles I've
been more of a MATLAB sort of person
less that's the way we engineers that's
the way we've brought up so along with a
bit of C++ so that's I'm making the
transition I've been forced to and you
can't be just use Python so I'm
getting there slowly and they'll sleep
coming on to these PI data events helps
no end so my I actually I I did set up a
start-up a couple of years ago which
does on-page optimization by machine
learning but now I'm I'm working as a
pure data scientist rather than sort of
general CTO data scientists and
entrepreneurs of notice I'm focusing on
the data science part so that's my
transition it may seem a bit of a crazy
journey but this is where I am at the
moment so I thought I start with just a
recap on clustering for data scientists
and so obviously collection of objects
deemed to be similar and this is a
problem with inputs and no no outlets
generally and you're using some notion
of similarity so it you can't actually
define what a cluster is because it
depends on the way you're determining
the similarity between objects and yeah
whilst you you have no outputs to
compare if if you're using some
performance metrics you may you may be
of comparing your groupings with some
kind of structure or so you could if
you're iteratively improving your
clustering algorithm you could say that
it's you have outputs so where did
clustering come from so it came really
from anthropology study of humans and
it's still being used today in in this
field so you can see here tated sort of
race segmented by DNA or DNA is
obviously a very high dimensional
problem but here it's been nicely
transformed in two dimensions so we can
see we can quite easily see clusters the
proximity to each other
highlighted different colors and nice
little faith
those are the same sort of pair of 1930s
it's also used by psychologists to group
people according to certain attributes
generating these psychological profiles
you may call young for example there are
many there diverse applications there's
a few here so outlier detection is one
recommender systems so generally you're
just helping users deal with an overload
of information an outlier is obviously
something that's far away from cluster
or other clusters it's used in image
processing for the purposes of say
compression for example and you can
actually cluster time-series but none of
these are the application I'm going to
talk about which is text clustering two
main processes behind clustering which I
think we're all aware of so one is
exploratory analysis so from a data
mining perspective understanding the
data set and you can use it as a
standalone tool to just just do that
also it may be it may be a component of
sort of supervised learning process so
you may want to cluster your data before
you apply models to it so what are
considerations when we are getting ready
to do
clustering do we first of all we want to
think about the way we're partitioning
do we want a single level like a flat
structure or do we they're more
interested in multi-level clusters like
a hierarchy because I've seen you know
attending kaggle competitions I've seen
that people often just jump into k-means
or something without even really
thinking about the data said that
they're looking at for example we need
to consider separation should can-can
objects belong to multiple groups
or can an object only be within one
group and the way we do we actually
define similarity do we use some kind of
distance like Euclidean distance as the
crow flies or do we are we looking at
something like density continuity and
also yeah funny we want us to think
about the dimensions so what the example
I showed earlier was a clear example
with DNA you'd struggle to when you've
got a crazy number of dimensions so you
need to think about that so my use case
is is search keywords search keywords
ohms the company I'm working for it's
got analytics SEO if they hold a little
data regarding keywords and they
basically query Google and other search
engines on a large scale and it build up
a picture for the clients of who so
which keywords your ranking for so say
this is a client I have pages belonging
to that domain and they they have a
certain number of keywords that they
they rank for so you can then go from
the other side you can look at other
pages that rank for the same keywords
you find out who is your competition
sometimes there are sort of surprises
because your online competition may not
be if you're a retailer say may not be
the same as your typical high street
competition so for example snow and rock
they sell snowboards they assumed that
there they would be competing with ski
shops and ski suppliers but they were
mainly competing to say Debenhams or
mainstream retailers so you got you're
gathering a lot of keywords and the
ratio of so on the left you have your
common keywords the keywords at the you
rank for everybody's record and the
opportunity keywords on the right so
you're both so these are keywords that
you don't rank for currently but if if
you started to incorporate them into
your website you might rank for these
and therefore it's an opportunity but
there are far more on that side so with
this price it's safer this is example
for a law firm you come up with all
these fantastic keywords but you have a
hundred thousand of them and you can't
just you know pass them on to a client
so yeah you go you've got a lot of data
to play with how do you go about
presenting these to a client the clients
got a few questions the clients got
their own you know their own structure
on their website so they you know
they've determined how to structure
their website so they they've made
assumptions about what people are
searching for and they they they often
want to know does my website structure
match what my my client base is
searching for online who made my in my
sort of domain and then secondly where
where is the money what you know I've
got a hundred thousand keywords to
optimize what is the quickest route to
cash you know and you can start to work
with which kids have a my search volume
which you have no hope of competing for
you might be it might be you know Amazon
of you know God covering a lot of your
keywords you might might be very
difficult to move in in certain areas
but there may be key areas where you can
you can absorb these keywords and make
them a part of your website and I'm
finally yeah there's relevancy of
keywords you get a lot of you might be
ranking for for words that just really
have nothing to do with your business so
yeah this is just underlying those sort
of website like structure that clients
want to see
they want to get this sort of they want
to get visual insights and people deal
very well with structure people like
ordinance they like hierarchy so this is
the base of the remit there's also the
the idea of allowing users to feedback
in to start to adjust clusters and
groups with it and give their own input
so how do we take the cluster text now
slavi here introduced me he actually did
a really good talk
about a month ago on Lda which was
really a bag of words with bag of words
approach but it the thing with that
approach it doesn't it doesn't give you
this this hierarchy I was looking for
you can actually use good old k-means
clustering if you're using the correct
distance measure because really you're
the values that you're a clustering art
to do with word frequencies and of
course when when you're clustering Texas
is very high-dimensional very sparse
vectors so
decided upon an hierarchical clustering
I want to bring structure to our thanks
data so two main types agglomerative and
divisive so and if you think about the
deterministic it's not like k-means
where you might run in the assign your
starting points then you iterate here
you every time you do it you get the
same result agglomerative you start with
sort of many singleton clusters and you
start you just go through them you're
merging two at a time yeah and again
divisive is basically the opposite so
you're you're just splitting you go in
the opposite direction you're splitting
large cluster into so much smaller so
how do you determine when to merge you
need some kind of like a sort of a glom
bration
facts old method okay so there are
there's a concept of a linkage type so
you can choose you're just comparing the
similarity of items right so you might
compare the two most similar items in
two clusters before you make your
decision to join them or you might
compare the two most distillate
dissimilar elements and
so yeah the problem with both of these
approaches they're quite sensitive to
outliers as I'll demonstrate so if we
were clustering countries in the
Americas
using and within those classes there
were cities you might you might join by
the single single approach you might
bring together Havana and Miami but with
the sort of the other approach you might
bring together a remote outpost in
Alaska with Santiago de Cuba if you're
going to join those two countries and
you can see the problems it might cause
because there you've sort of absorbed
part of Canada as well and it's kind of
it may not be the best approach so there
are other ways so average link looks at
similarity between all pairs of items in
the two clusters well as you imagine it
it's it's the number of items in the
first cluster times the number the
second so this computation is very
expensive there's a way around this
though and that's to take the centroid
so you're just looking at the similarity
between the center of those two clusters
and then here's a method that's it's
quite prevalent and it's to do with
minimizing the variation within within
the cluster basically the ward when he
defined it he said you could basically
minimize any function that reflects your
your purpose I think it's a good way to
look at it keep keep your options open
what you're doing is you're you're
minimizing the summer squared error and
you're reducing your variation before
you make any decision whether to to to
join cluster together also divide so I'm
just going to talk briefly on divisive
clustering
it's a top-down approach and when you
when you split Lee used awards criteria
you can say yeah it's it's a more of a
global view and apparently it's more
efficient it's not as far as I know
implemented in Python or scikit-learn so
I haven't looked at it one challenge you
have to have is to to avoid getting
really tiny clusters you also you have
to have a stop point before you you
basically D cluster everything so again
looking at your data set you need to you
know match a similarity measure to your
task in hand so if your data is purely
numerical you might want to start using
Manhattan distance so this is basic
distance bit of Pythagoras they're two
dimensions business the crow flies
if your data is binary you can apply
some Jaccard coefficient but the text
should really use something like cosine
similarity because the way you represent
your data is going to be easily in the
vector full of frequency of particular
terms which could be word which could be
a topic which could be a phrase for
example so you can basically take the
two vectors and perform this cosine
similarity it's quite straightforward
so within Python
we're very lucky to have scikit-learn
and its
agglomerative clustering module it's the
same yes
there's also k-means clustering
available I'm going to go through the
process I went through with with
agglomerative clustering so one one sort
of piece of advice is try and if
possible if you do have extra features
available I would add them into your
data set so I knew which pages the each
keyword was was ranking for so I
actually went to the URL of each page
and took words from the URL and
aggregated these to the keyword set so
it has the variation of the data set and
yet brings in sort of some inherent
structure from the from the website so I
was able by just running a function here
which joins the words from the URL to
the to the keyword once you've done that
yeah so basically extracting the
keywords there some advice on prepping
your text
like I said add some features also
stemming words can be great idea because
some words are very similar but they
might have an apostrophe or you know
different ending but I would be a little
bit careful choosing your stemmer
because there are some that are quite
severe there's within NLT kay there's
there's one called snowball stir which
actually takes plurals into account
things like that so it's a bit a little
bit less harsh but still gives you what
you want low frequency cutoff so you're
really interested in words that to
hardly appear basically so you might
want to experiment with this value you
can set it and same four words that have
just appear everywhere so they're not
really helping you and your objective
and clustering say another way another
useful features engrams so you're not
only clustering individual words you you
can look at diagrams and trigrams
whatever you want really as long as
you're keeping the ordering of the words
then it makes sense to basically
aggregate add features to yourself so
yeah foreign language is just difficult
with key words because you can like
resolve with we operate it in the french
market you might have english-language
keywords being searched for in France
but ideally you want to separate it
completely so you have two completely
separate analysis in French this is it's
a bit of a challenge really
so here
hurling the text and using a vectorizer
to doing all the things I said earlier
getting rid of some accents determining
like a token pattern where I had to spot
it weird and I'm decided to use one and
two word engrams what I'm doing at the
bottom there is I'm actually
transforming transforming this data
I'm just taking those two taking into
the space matrix basically it's mainly
zeros and I'm and I'm just plotting well
the data looks like at the bottom
oh yeah dimensionality is a whole topic
you could have a whole presentation on
that but they're pros and cons with text
analysis I think if you want to
visualize your result quickly I would
try and reduce the number of dimensions
and spectral clustering is one way to do
it so
what I'm doing here is I'm actually at
the top I'm taking the sparse matrix and
transforming into two dimensions and I'm
trying the the linkages I spoke about
earlier through the ward averaging
complete and I'm also you know trying
different distance measurements
Euclidean and cosine but there are
limitations here so for example in in
scikit-learn you can't so let's get this
right so yeah for Ward linkage you can
only have Euclidean distance which when
you're clustering text isn't ideal for
example so I think this is right that
relative recent library but they need to
I think they needs a universality of
distance metrics this is what it looks
like when you when you plot these this
is the data fit into two dimensions so
I've just selected eight clusters for
example out of I think three thousand
keywords and you can see some groups
emerging this is the width of Ward
linkage and it's it's quite effective
although you can probably observe this
not enough groupings there
I chose eight because it matched the
average number of pages per site in this
set of domains I was looking up so you'd
have you know our experiments try
different numbers of groupings he's
using cosine distance but because Ward
linkage didn't support it I had to use
average linkage you can see it's like
it's a very different approach and it's
actually here's nicely clumped but here
everything is spreading out from a
central point and the result may not be
particularly nice to
to look at so and another thing you do
is plot a dendrogram and this one looks
like broke it down into five clusters
dendrograms
I don't know what you guys think as data
scientist I personally I wouldn't
preserve one to a client a struggle to
present it to my team to be honest and
they it sort of gives us a little even
seal of approval you know they can see
that your data scientists you're doing
your technical things but I wouldn't
yeah outside of the company you're going
to have problems presenting one of these
things I think so to assess the quality
of your clusters you can apply various
metrics so you can do you can you can
examine the clusters internally and to
see how pure they are homogeneous you
can also apply external metrics so you
can compare groups of clusters and and
you get measurements such as the
adjusted brand index normalized
information index which brings me on to
topic modeling which is yeah quite quite
a task usually when you run an algorithm
you you're able to extract the most
common for each cluster you can extract
the most common terms per cluster but
then you can end up with like a huge
long string of meaningless words so one
way to deal with this is to take do the
sort of 90/10 rule or 8020 rule and take
which which ever words have 90 percent
whichever words fill up 90% of
probability but you might want to have a
cut-off because you could still have
about 10
you've got a produce something that's
meaningful another problem is when you
start to stem words they all you get all
the stem words appearing in the topic
names so you have to build on well what
I did was to build an understanding
module to make the words complete again
but this has varying another impact as
well so hey hierarchical clustering
beyond - I've got a few minutes left so
here's something I decided to do I
figured with Python I was loading a lot
of data from a database doing some
analysis playing around with it and then
storing it back again we we started to
use this knows no sequel database called
elasticsearch yes some of you may be
familiar with this document store but it
does it has analyzers built-in and it
can do things like time frequency
inverse document frequency and stop
words and it has language specific
analyzers within the yeah as you store
the data you can just run these these
things on it so I really recommend
having a look at elasticsearch very easy
to get going you basically store a
document like this so I'm able to store
a page keyword who's our cheap holidays
in South Africa and I can run an
algorithm which does hierarchical
clustering off the shelf I can run that
algorithm directly on the database so
it's doing all my stemming it's doing
what my text processing is doing dealing
with multiple language supports it
really does everything you need so you
don't have to spend all this time go
include the individual steps and then
finding out limitations of individual
models for example
so I'm gonna try and go straight now so
but this is server just run this now
this is just me running clustering on
set of documents in elasticsearch let's
press return and boom it's just
clustered all my documents for me and
it's come up with this tunnel the topic
labeling for me this is just a flat
structuring but there is there is a
hierarchical option available as well
but I just thought it was a very nice
solution and I success you cannot use
it's really powerful for text search
obviously it's sort of all optimized for
this sort of thing there they currently
have three clustering algorithms
the first two are included for free but
this is the third one in that you have
to pay for and the third one is like
full hierarchical clustering so I
recommend you look into it okay I can
sort of demonstrate it here so if I do a
Google search on there they call this
demo page where you can just run a
search for some some words and they have
this visualization which this is just
set to frequency of word occurrence and
it's a very nice way of just visualizing
your your set of keywords for example so
something else I did was to run it on
our keyword set so I got I just wrote a
script in Python to convert to the
format that this visualizer reads is
sort of like a JavaScript object and I
wait it's a bit too zoomed in here but I
waited each cluster by the sort of
opportunity in terms of return on
investment for the client so they can
see very quickly you know which which
words to focus on it doesn't show up
very well here but when it was
interested I can don't worry after so
yeah maybe tie up this sort of
visualization with elasticsearch you can
access elastic so it's quite easy from
Python and yeah and that's basically it
so thank you very much
anyone have any questions
yep another pack just perish yeah very
short terms usually oh sorry yeah so
ever been using it on large text
documents or very small ones effective
lethal you say yeah pretty much just to
do with not this like with elasticsearch
you just can have box to text to deal
with things like more like this kind of
queries and the issue that I found when
using elasticsearch particular when
trying to do something really and you
know along the lines with clustering
it's quite often the document lengths
can have like an impact so as a result
we actually have like lists of words
that we want to basically cluster with
an elastic search and each list of words
really represents like a user's
interests I see no problem with taking
that approach
yeah yeah it's just it's very
interesting cuz this is the first time
I've had costing elasticsearch so it's
very and insightful you should look up
there carrot too that's the algorithm I
put the links in the presentation
distribute okay thank you
I wanted to hear your opinion on
combining different types of features in
a document feature vector so say for
example you have at tf-idf features but
then you have other features as well
which might be on a different scale
so maybe categorical features that might
be binary and do you think it's okay to
combine those types of features into one
long vector or what's your view on that
it's a good question
it's not something I've done before
maybe there's somebody who is better
qualified you can answer that so
combining categorical with text vector
this guy here you might have an answer
if you combine categorical and numerical
features so it's kind of you have try to
keep it pure binary or keep it pure
numerical but okay so keep it pure is
the message yeah any other questions
yep yep
so how do you yes just asking how do you
come up with a cutoff for agglomerative
clustering or divisive I guess well it
depends on use case for us the clients
wanted to see initially some structure
that matched their own website so I just
took a straw poll of all the websites in
their market and just looked at the
certain number of pages per site I think
you're just experiment any other
questions
I haven't used thought about it I'm
quite new to this field myself so far
we've just been summarizing data and
doing it on a like a batch process as
you say so yeah
performance of keiretsu so I'm actually
going back to your previous point I
think in terms of online character is
great because it just acts on whatever
data is available in the database so in
a way if you're continuously updating
database it is a form of online in a
sense in terms of performance yeah there
is it does start to slow down by the
demonstration I just did I think was a
thousand documents is just take a sample
of my overall set but the thing is for
us is just a one-time action and it
happens in the background it's not in
it's not part of the front-end so it
wasn't a key feature but yeah they do
they offer different options they offer
I think for this lingo 3G algorithm they
offer different pricing categories and
you should talk to them directly to find
out ways to improve your performance